what's going on guys axlebeatz here
again for anime uproar and recently we
covered all of the abilities of the
straw hat crew and since the video
seemed to be one that you guys really
enjoyed we wanted to continue our dive
into the crew by talking about all of
their backstories all in one
comprehensive video as always if you
enjoy these dives into the world of one
piece be sure to leave a like and
comment letting us know what to talk
about next time you can also subscribe
to the channel for more content in the
future as subscribing is the best way to
stay up to date on all of our videos and
it's a totally free way to support us
but with all the youtube stuff out of
the way let's get into the video
spoilers and all so as always let's
start things off with the captain of the
crew monkey d luffy he is the son of the
most wanted man in the world the
revolutionary monkey the dragon and the
grandson of the hero of the marines
monkey d garp that said we know very
little about his mother but if you are
interested in a look at some of the most
popular fan theories we actually did a
video discussing that pretty recently a
link to that will be in the description
down below luffy didn't grow up knowing
dragon instead he was being raised by
his grandfather and garp was definitely
a bit of a rough guardian famously both
leaving luffy to survive on his own in
the wild and throwing him down a ravine
all to toughen him up in preparation of
becoming a strong marine though
things kind of went astray on garp's
plan when luffy met shanks and the
red-haired pirates they were staying in
fucha village for an entire year and
luffy became completely enamored with
them deciding that he wanted to become a
pirate and join shanks's crew however
shanks kind of laughed off luffy joining
the crew because he couldn't swim and he
was too young despite the fact that
shanks himself was on roger's crew at
the same age and there are just plenty
of pirates who can't swim because of
devil fruits of course prior to the year
in fuchsia shanks actually stole the
gomu gomu nomi or as we later found out
the hitohitomi mythical model nika from
the world government this ultimately
being what led to it ending up in
fuchsia village where luffy ate it soon
after eating the fruit and becoming a
rubber man a mountain bandit named
higuma would kidnap him and try to throw
him into the ocean however a sea king
would attack eating higuma in the
process and leaving shanks to swoop in
at the last moment to save luffy but
losing his arm in the process luffy
would go on to promise to become king of
the pirates mimicking the words of
goldie roger unknowingly and inspiring
shanks to give him his straw hat having
luffy promise to give it back one day
when he became a great pirate from here
garp would return to fuchsia and take
luffy into the mountains to be raised by
the mountain bandit to don here luffy
meets ace and works his butt off to win
him over with sabo soon to follow they'd
be at odds for quite some time however
one day a member of the blue jam pirates
would abduct luffy beat him down for
hours and try to get information on
where the boys were hiding their
treasure despite this luffy was an
absolute chad lad held strong and
refused to sell out his friends showing
both his loyalty and how much he cared
about ace and sabo from the moment that
the boys rescued luffy from the pirates
luffy was officially accepted into their
group sparring together hunting together
and eventually sharing sake and becoming
brothers
things wouldn't exactly stay all
sunshine and rainbows for long though as
saba would be brought back to his
parents home and grey terminal would be
set on fire with both luffy and ace tied
down by blue jam within it as all this
went down sabo would cross paths with
dragon and tell him that the nobles were
behind the fire while luffy and ace
would manage to escape their ropes only
to be found by blue jam and his men the
two of them are barely able to hold
their own but at the last moment best
mom de don shows up to help ace fend off
the pirates as the rest of the mountain
bandits grab luffy and run after the
fire sabo would set sail as a world
noble was arriving however the celestial
dragon felt insulted that another ship
was in their path and ordered sabo's
ship to be shot down of course we all
know that sabo survived and that he was
rescued by the revolutionaries but at
the time luffy and ace believed he was
dead and it devastated them this though
acted as a catalyst for each of the
brothers helping them to realize that
they weren't ready to become pirates yet
and that they were going to need to
become stronger if they were serious
about heading over to sea but most
importantly it gave luffy a drive to
become strong enough to protect his
friends and filled him with a wish to
never lose another person again luffy
and ace would begin training together
more seriously fighting off the giant
beasts of the mountain or bandits or
sparring and even dealing with garp when
he visited and over the next seven years
they would prepare until ace set out to
sea
then finally three years after that
luffy would set out on his own famously
knocking down the king of the coast that
took shanks's arm on his way out moving
on to zorro he was born in the east blue
but explained that he left some kind of
old life behind once he decided to
become an invincible swordsman he
trained in shimotsuki village under
koshiro and even as a child he was much
better than most of the adults around
him however he was never able to beat
koshiro's daughter kawina while training
here zoro also crossed paths with
kawina's grandfather and the creator of
the wado ichimonji and enma shimotsuki
kozaburo kozaburo taught zoro the
magical word tsunachi that summons all
the strength in his heart despite zoro
never really wanting to use it because
it sounds kind of weird one day when
zoro was training on zone kozaburo asked
him if the dojo was boring to him but
when zoro explained that he was doing
extra practice because he kept losing to
kauina kosoboro decided to gift him a
pair of real swords also explaining to
zoro that every sword has its own
personality that needs to be bent to its
master's will going on to say that even
cursed swords are just a sign of great
quality because their powerful will
scares off the weak and this is
something that zorro carries with him
throughout the entire series most
notably early on we see him taking
kitetsu despite it being a cursed sword
and always just respecting and even
talking to his swords throughout the
series back to yanzoro though he would
go on to lose to queena 2 000 times
then deciding to challenge her to a
private match with real swords to finish
things once and for all that said
swapping to real swords
really just didn't make a difference as
queena still absolutely bodied him and
like it it wasn't even close the next
person to embarrass him that badly would
probably be mihawk if we're being honest
but while he didn't win the fight it did
lead him to having this heart heart with
kawina he cried and told her that he
dreamed to become the world's greatest
swordsman and she told him that she had
the same dream but that her father told
her that women couldn't become
swordsmasters because eventually a man's
body would just become more developed
than her own and the gap that she held
over others would diminish quickly which
like
kinda a dick move on a dad's part and
when we look at some of the best
swordsmen in the series they don't tend
to be the burliest of men
like yeah zoro's kinda buff but like
look at mihawk and pre-time skip shanks
the dudes are strong but they're not
exactly beefcakes it's pretty clear that
in the world of one piece swordsmanship
is more about technique than it is about
power so koshiro kind of just sucks on
that one but you know no one's perfect
anyways zorro kind of blows up on her
frustrated on her just willing to give
up like that despite dominating over him
for so long to him it meant that no
victory over her could ever be justified
because regardless of if he beat her the
next day or the next year the idea that
she was at a disadvantage because she
was a woman would always be there to
tame his win he wanted to win because he
was more skilled not because she was a
girl so here they would make a promise
that odds or conditions be damned
one of them would become the world's
greatest swordsman no matter what and
you know what no one of them would
become the world's greatest swords
person take that koshiro however things
did not go as planned because in what
might be oda's worst writing choice ever
queena
and i cannot stress this enough
fell down the stairs and died the next
day off-screen what a
wild choice
of course there's always the tashigi is
actually kawina theory and all that but
until we have a real tangible payoff to
that i think this is easily one of the
biggest black marks on the series to me
sure people have accidents all the time
but i don't think major impactful
characters like kawina should just be
falling down the stairs to their death
again off screen but you'll have to let
me know if you agree down in the
comments either way zorro is filled with
anger disappointment and grief and he
approaches koshiro to ask him for
queen's sword the wato ichimonji saying
that he will use it to fulfill their
promise and become a swordsman so great
that his name will reach her in the
heavens eventually zoro would become
aware of dracul mihawk the current
greatest swordsman in the world and set
off to see so that he could challenge
him being zoro though he would get lost
along the way and never find his way
back home needing to rely instead on
bounty hunting to survive and earning
the title of pirate hunter he also meets
johnny and yosuku along the way and he
would even be approached by baroque
works to
broke work for them
but he turned that down unless he could
become the leader of the organization
going on to kill mr seven the agent who
tried to hire him in self-defense
finally zoro would end up in shells town
where he killed helmepo's pet wolf who
was attacking a girl named rika zorro
agreed to be tied down for a month as
punishment which just about brings us to
where luffy finds him on to usopp the
third official member to join the crew
and probably the one with the most
simple backstory he was the son of
yassop a marksman on shanks's crew and
he and his mother were left behind as
his father went to become a pirate
however rather than becoming resentful
or upset that his dad left them to get
pirate milk and never returned usopp
would rationalize that being a pirate
must be something so amazing that it was
worth leaving his family behind
which is both wholesome
and pathetically sad usopp from a very
young age picked up the habit of telling
lies most frequently he would run around
the streets yelling that pirates were
coming this would lead to the villagers
chasing him or throwing things at him
until he left the village that said the
reason that he was doing this was that
his mother was severely ill and he
thought that yelling that pirates were
coming that yasop was coming would keep
her spirits up as she fought the zits
hope only goes so far though and his
mother would eventually pass away from
that disease leaving usopp totally alone
and as you might expect from someone his
age in that situation he kept yelling
about pirates throughout the village to
keep the attention of others and while
on the surface they were all very
annoyed by it we see later when usab
leaves that the entire village is
waiting for him and disappointed when he
doesn't show up it became something that
was part of their daily routines and it
brought a lot of energy and life to the
town that said of course the usa pirates
that he trained would eventually go on
to take over for him of course though
the most important person in the town
after his mother passed away for usop
was kaya a rich but sick girl who usab
would tell stories to in order to cheer
her up in the exact same way that he did
for his mother number number four sanji
vinsmoke was born in the north flew to a
royal family of the german kingdom his
father judge had genetically enhanced
sanji and his brothers before their
birth to remove their emotions and give
them superhuman abilities thus making
them the perfect soldiers
that said sanji's mother sora was
against genetically modifying babies for
some reason and decided to take a drug
to counteract judges efforts
this didn't go as planned as only sanji
would be born normal and the effects of
the drug severely weakened her own body
sora is also where sanji fell in love
with cooking one day he decided to cook
for his mother to help her recover and
despite falling on the way to the
hospital and completely ruining the dish
she ate the entire thing smiled and said
it was delicious
and you know what we need more soraa
love in the community judge on the other
hand planned for his four boys to lead
the german military and began training
them very young but with sanji's more or
less human body he fell behind and
became the target of his brother's
bullying something judge just didn't
care to stop the only one really being
kind to sanji at any point in his
childhood other than his mother was his
sister reiju who would sometimes tend to
his wounds at the same time while sora
was promoting sanji's love of cooking
judge was all but forbidding it he
eventually realized that sanji was
unlike his brothers and would never
become a superhuman and decided to hold
a false funeral for him then choosing to
keep sanji hidden away in the dungeon
with an iron mask over his face it was
also in this dungeon where sanji first
read about the all blue which would
become his future dream in life sanji
would spend six months in that dungeon
but once the germa kingdom crossed the
red line and entered the east blue reiju
helped him to escape the cell so that he
could be free and become a chef during
his escape he ran into his father and it
was decided that sanji would be free to
go as long as he never told anyone that
they were related so sanji renounces his
title as prince and when the germa began
attacking the isle of korzia sanji made
his way onto the cruise liner called the
orbit where he began to learn more about
cooking he would stay there for the next
two years until the orbit was attacked
by red leg zeph only for sanji to
declare that he can't die here because
he needed to find the all blue as the
red leg pirates were attacking this ship
though a massive storm broke out and
sanji ends up falling off the ship into
the ocean leading zeph to dive in after
him and save him both the red leg ship
and the orbit would be torn apart in the
storm and zeph and sanji would wash
ashore on a large rock in the middle of
the ocean way too high up for them to go
down for food or to make it back up if
they ever tried to make matters worse
the island was completely barren with
only some puddles of rainwater to keep
them hydrated and just two bags of food
to keep them alive sanji was given the
smaller bag as he was a child and he was
ordered to sit on the other side of the
island to keep an eye out for ships he
thought that he would have about five
days worth of food and he could ration
it out to probably make it last about
20. on the fifth day a ship passed but
he was unable to get their attention by
day 25 he was officially out of food and
begins thinking back on all the food he
had wasted in his life by day 50 he was
skin and bones
and by day 70 he decided to check on
zeph
willing to kill the old man and take
what food he had left if he needed to in
order to survive
but then sanji cuts into zeff's bag and
there wasn't a speck of food inside of
it rather it had been full of treasure
and zeph had gone without food the
entire time in fact in order to give
sanji as much food as possible zeph
instead decided to eat his own leg even
though it meant he would never be a
pirate again
a way more badass version of the story
than in the anime when asked why he
would do that zeff simply said that it
was because they had the same dream that
being to find the all blue the old man
begins talking about how he's been
stranded at sea many times and each time
he wonders how many men would die at sea
cursing its vastness for being left
without food he talks about how nice it
would be to find a restaurant in the
middle of the sea and sanji promises
that when they get out of here alive
he'll help zeph open the restaurant and
it would be another 15 days totaling at
85 before the two were saved and as they
promised soon after they opened the
baratier the restaurant at sea were the
cooks fight and sanji would stay there
for nearly a decade with the old man
learning to become one of the best chefs
in the world and being taught the black
leg style of fighting along the way and
here he would remain until luffy
eventually came and asked him to join
his crew the final east blue member nami
was born in the oycott kingdom a place
completely torn apart by war with almost
no survivors
she was only a baby when nochiko would
pick her up and together they would
eventually be found by a female marine
who was barely holding on to life for
herself this being bellamyr bellamir
managed to bring her new adopted
daughters back to kokoyashi village
where she insisted the doctor saved them
before looking at her luckily all three
of them would survive and become a
family and while they were happy for the
most part they were also very poor and
it definitely puts stress on them
bellamir would often skip meals or
refashion nojiko's clothes for nami to
make ends meet because of this nami
picked up the bad habit of stealing and
this was typically for things like books
so that she could learn more about
navigation and creating c charts the
village leader genzo would often bring
nami back to bellamir and bellamir would
just flirt with him to make him
flustered and get nami off the hook
something we kind of see nami picking up
when she's older as she definitely uses
her sexuality to her advantage much more
than any other member on the crew one
day nami would angrily yell at bellamire
for the way they were living she hated
that bellamir skipped meals she hated
wearing hand-me-downs and she hated that
bellamere had to put up a front that
everything was okay even going so far as
to say that they weren't real family
because they weren't connected by blood
and that she wished that she had been
adopted by a rich family
obviously that isn't really the case and
it was just a child lashing out because
she felt guilty that she was making
bellamire's life difficult and believing
that bellamir would be happier without
her around nami ran to genzo's home and
he told her all about how bellamir had
found her in nojiko and how they brought
meaning to her life and because of that
nami didn't have to worry about making
bellamir unhappy but just as nami was
about to head home and apologize and
make up with bellamir the arlong pirates
attacked claiming all of kokoyashi
village as their territory and declaring
that arlong was the ruler of this region
they set in place a monthly tax where
every adult would need to pay 100 000
berries and every child would have to
pay fifty thousand
at first it seemed like bellamir would
be missed because her home was outside
of the town but at the last moment
someone noticed the smoke leaving her
home and the fish men marched over to
check it out and like i said bellamir
was already struggling at the best she
had a hundred thousand saved away for
herself but there was no way that she
could cover all three of them as arlong
enters her house bellamir drops him to
the ground immediately as she sticks a
gun into his mouth like an absolute chad
lass
but arlong just bites through it and by
the time nami and nojiko make it home
bellamir is having her arm crushed by
arlong's foot genzo speaks up saying
that the issue can easily be resolved
with money and that the extra plates at
bellamir's table were because he was
supposed to visit not because she has
children backing this up is that the
village registry says that bellamir
never married or had kids so everything
is set up to allow her to live
the village doctor tells nojiko and nami
that if they can manage to escape
bellamir can live because there's no
record of them being here
while the girls agree
nami begins to understand the difference
between the haves and the have-nots
saying that they need to leave or die
just because they don't have money
this obviously spurring the importance
of money in her eyes in the future so
bellamir manages to get herself back on
her feet and says thank goodness
with the 100 000 berries i saved i'll be
able to save my two children this money
is my children's share and i don't have
enough for myself telling guenzo that
she can't bring herself to say that she
doesn't have a family even if it meant
losing her life
the girls run up and they all hug and
apologize to each other and bellamir
tells arlong to leave them be which he
agrees to do if she dies quietly he
holds a gun up to her head and without
flinching she says her daughter's name
tells them that she loves them and our
lung pulls the trigger honestly this is
one of the best moments in terms of
sound design in the entire anime and
every single time i get there it just
hits me like a ton of bricks even so
there is no time to mourn as hachi finds
nami's sea charts and arlong decides to
take her prisoner genzo tries to stop
them but kirobi immediately cuts him
down which was always going to happen
not exactly the smartest move on genzo's
part but nami calls out saying that it's
okay no one has to try to save her just
so long as more people don't have to die
arlong has the villagers beaten down
sinks all of the ships in their ports
and leaves them all in the palm of his
flipper days later when everyone is
finally able to get up again they rally
a small force and decide to fight the
fishmen head-on but nami shows back up
and says that she joined the arlong
pirates as a cartographer she had even
been branded by their tattoo and given
wads of cash thinking that if she has
money and if she goes along with what
arlong has to say then she'll never have
to lose anyone genzo becomes enraged
that she would betray the memory of
bellamir and exiles nami from the town
and nojiko chases after her to find her
at bellamire's grave
nami recounts that bellamir told them to
live on and as long as they can survive
they will eventually come across good
times again
conversely even the government wasn't
going to help them because arlong sunk
so many of their ships already
so instead nami decided that she would
save the village by herself and buy it
back for 100 million berries she thinks
that if she has to ask for help from the
villagers then they're probably going to
get hurt again
declaring that she's never going to cry
and that she'll fight him alone for the
next eight years nami would work for
arlong drawing charts and in her spare
time she would sneak off to invade other
pirates crews and rob them blind until
she had enough money to buy back
kokoyashi village of course along this
journey she would run into luffy in
orangetown as she was trying to steal
buggy's treasure map and that would lead
to him saving their town
onto the grand line and drum island
where anthony anthony helicopter joins
the crew chopper was a red-nosed
reindeer who was bullied by all the
other reindeers and was never allowed to
join into their reindeer games
but one day santa came this
i think this is the wrong book um
one sec
ah yes here it is chopper was a blue
nosed reindeer who was also bullied by
all the other reindeer
and this is starting to feel like the
same guy either way chopper was already
considered an outcast when he found the
hitohito nomi but once he ate it he was
essentially exiled by gaining the
intelligence of a human chopper also
gained self-awareness and realized that
the other reindeer treated him
differently and he decided to leave them
and find a place where he belonged next
he tried to live with the humans turning
into his human form and approaching them
however this human form looked more like
an ape man or a yeti and the humans
thought he was a monster and began
shooting at him but there was one man dr
hirolook who instead took him in and
even allowed him to become his assistant
while here look would teach chopper the
basics of medicine he wasn't exactly the
most medically savvy doctor himself he
was kind of a quack so yes chopper might
have learned some things from him but
the real things he would take away from
here look were his philosophy on life
and his dreams like i said here look
wasn't a good doctor but he was a good
person
he taught chopter to believe that all
diseases could be cured that the jolly
roger was a symbol of hope and that you
should always do everything you can to
help others even if it puts your own
life at risk
here look himself was also sick and when
his condition worsened he kicked chopper
out of his house so that he wouldn't
have to watch his mentor die but once
chopper learned what was actually
happening he promised to find it here
and set out for the amiyudake mushroom
this was marked in one of the medical
books that chopper read with a skull and
crossbones the same symbol of hope that
hirolook had taught him that pirates
raise chopper would risk his life to
find the amudake even crossing his old
herd who tried to kill him by the time
he got the mushroom and made it back to
hirolik's house he was beaten to near
death covered in cuts and bruises with a
cracked antler and a broken leg
here luck managed to treat chopper's
injuries and even reattached his antlers
with a brace
but he was still filled with grief about
having let his adopted son get so hurt
on his own behalf as such hirlok would
decide to take the amyodoki medicine
that chopper had supplied for him even
knowing that it was actually a fatal
poison dr kureha would be the one to
explain to chopper what he had actually
done and tells chopper that being kind
isn't enough to save people you actually
need medical skills and training or
you're only going to harm them however
here look would not let chopper be the
cause of his death king waffle had put
out a notice that all the country's
doctors had fallen ill in an attempt to
lure kureha and here look out and while
krejha was too smart and calculated to
act on that herelook couldn't stop
himself from trying to save anyone in
danger even if it was likely a trap he
knew that it was a one in a million
chance that all the doctors were sick
but the country needed those doctors if
anything happened and he was willing to
risk his life on the off chance that he
could possibly save them so here look
makes his way up to drum castle where
waffle reveals that it was indeed a trap
and here look just smiles saying
thank god no one is actually sick
here i was thinking that the country was
in crisis but it was all a little trick
he gives his whole speech about how a
man dies not when he eats a poisonous
mushroom not when he gets an incurable
disease or when he is shot but when he
is forgotten
then turning to dalton and telling him
that a monster will soon arrive and that
that monster is his son asking them not
to hurt him
but with that here look raises his cup
of sake into the air exclaims that he
had a wonderful life and thanks chopper
before blowing himself up to ensure that
chopper isn't the cause of his death
chopra arrives soon after in a blind
rage but dalton manages to stop him and
tells him to leave and not die for this
diseased country convincing him to
survive rather than sacrifice himself
chopper then heads to koreha's house and
begs to be taught medicine saying that
he will become the panacea himself a
doctor who can cure anything
for the next six years chopper would
study under correct to learn medicine
until the straw hats arrived on drum
island and asked him to join their crew
on to number six and my personal
favorite straw hat nico robin robin was
born on the island of ohara and when she
was two years old her mother nico olivia
left her with her brother as she
journeyed to see to find the true
history of the world and study the
poneglyphs robin herself would also pick
up an interest in archaeology even
beginning to read books within the tree
of knowledge at a very young age with
clover's permission robin's new
caretakers though were not as welcoming
as clover was rogey olivia's brother
would yell at or beat robin telling her
that she was unwanted and that she was
to stay out of sight even denying her
the ability to join family celebrations
while he might not have liked robin for
plenty of reasons the most likely one
was that her devil fruit often scared
other people with the parents of other
children even saying that she was a
demon that needed to be avoided the only
real place that robin ever felt she
belonged at was the tree of knowledge as
such she would spend all of her
available time there studying even
passing the archaeology exam at only
eight years old and becoming an official
scholar
but when she said that she wanted to
learn about the true history of the
world just like her mother had clover
said she would be banned from the
library if she kept spying on them as
there was no way that she could have
known about the true history otherwise
robin left the tree of knowledge crying
and ran to the beats where she met
jaguar d sull who had just washed ashore
they became quick friends over the next
few days as he worked on building his
raft but things changed when he found
out where he was
after learning that he was on ohara and
that he had been speaking with the
daughter of nico olivia he warns her
that there are battleships on their way
to destroy the island because of their
research meanwhile nico olivia herself
had managed to escape from a marine ship
with the help of saul and made it back
to ohara she warns the people at the
tree of knowledge that the marines were
aware of what they were doing and that
they were on route to kill them but the
scholars decided that they would try to
stay and protect the tree of knowledge
and all of the wisdom that they had
worked to accumulate over the years
olivia quickly leaves when she hears
that cp-9 had showed up and robin
returns to the tree to ask where her
mother is but olivia wanted to cut ties
with robin because she was a criminal
and didn't want her daughter branded
with their association olivia had told
clover to keep them separate so he
denies to robin that olivia was even on
the island but they don't get much time
to talk about this as cp9 arrives and
begins to search the tree outside the
people of ohara are being forced onto
evacuation boats as nico olivia is being
detained by cp9 and spandin they're soon
joined by the rest of the archaeologists
who are brought out of the tree and
clover tells robin to escape but she
refuses and olivia finally sees her
daughter when the marines find the
poneglyph hidden under the tree clover
asks to speak to the gorosei through
spandin's transponder snail he starts to
ask them questions about the void
century but before he's able to say the
name of the ancient kingdom the gorosei
orders him to be killed the buster call
is triggered and robin calls out to
olivia to ask if she is her mother then
just as bellamere had showed her love
for her daughter by saying they were
family olivia tries to protect robin by
denying they were family robin pushes
again saying i'm robin i've grown but
don't you remember me someday i want to
be able to hold your hand and walk with
you i've studied hard and became an
archaeologist and i can read the
podoglyphs too a sentence which sealed
her fate as a target of the world
government as shells start dropping from
the buster call spawndeen and his men
turn tail and run and robin is given a
moment with her mother they don't get
too much time though as saul shows up
and olivia asks him to take robin off
the island robin of course wants to stay
with her mother but olivia tells her
that she is a scholar and she must know
that history is an asset to humanity and
charges her daughter with the duty of
passing that history on even if o'hara
perishes they shouldn't give up on the
future that she'll be living in with her
final words to robin asking her to live
her life to the fullest for her as saul
carries robin away he tells her to be
proud of her honorable mother and
honorable island that fought so hard
against the world and also tells robin
to pass on the history of this island
saul continues to protect her all the
way to the escape ship but the other
passengers refused to let the monster
girl who is the daughter of a criminal
on board as it would put them in danger
as well
she keeps running with saul but
eventually aokiji shows up he and saul
discuss the idea of justice and how it's
malleable and changes depending on where
you stand and alkiji even says that he
doesn't like what's happening but it's
for the good of the future but then the
passenger ship full of innocence was
absolutely obliterated by a young akainu
who says that if they're going to wipe
out a nation they should do it
thoroughly aokiji is disgusted by
akinu's actions but still needs to
fulfill his duties he begins to freeze
saul solid as the giant tells robin to
run and that the sea is a vast place and
as long as she lives someday she will be
able to find true friends who will
protect her and that no one is born into
the world to be alone finally he reminds
her that in times of hardship all she
has to do is laugh and keep smiling and
that if she can do that she will
eventually find her friends aokiji comes
to the conclusion that absolute justice
drives the man insane so he decides to
let the seed that saul protected grow
and see what becomes of it he prepares a
path of ice that will keep her safe
until the next island but before she
leaves he reminds her that he is not her
friend and should she cause any trouble
he will be the first one to come find
her and with that robin gets in the boat
to row away from her destroyed home as
she quietly cries and tries to keep
laughing like saul wanted her to do the
government would go on to put a 79
million berry bounty on her calling her
the devil of ohara and over the next 20
years robin would go on to live in
several homes in several cities on
several islands but no matter where she
went every time the story was the same
those who took her in would feel like
she was putting them in danger and
eventually they would either try to turn
her into the government for the money or
for their own safety
so instead she turned to pirates and
thugs hoping that the enemies of her
enemy would be her friend but even so
when they were in danger of being caught
the pirates would try to turn her in or
blame her for them being targeted she
was told that her existence was a sin
that it was a plague and that it was
evil but she carried on kept running and
searched for the poneglyphs as she went
all until at 24 she found herself at
baroque works and crocodile took an
immediate interest in her as someone who
could read the ponoglyphs his plan was
to use her to find pluton and conquer
the world but four years later she would
of course cross paths with the straw
hats and eventually join their crew
crewmate number 7 is cuddy flam or as he
is known now frankie frankie was born in
the south blue but he found his way to
the grand line aboard his parents pirate
ship that said they weren't exactly the
kindest parents and literally threw him
off the ship into the ocean he was
luckily saved by the legendary
shipwright tom who took him in as his
apprentice after seeing him make cannons
out of scrap frankie had a bit of a
rivalry with tom's other apprentice
iceberg who's actually the one who gave
him the nickname frankie because cuddy
flam sounded strange both frankie and
iceberg would learn shipbuilding under
tom and while iceberg focused more on
traditional ships frankie tended to
build warships called battle frankie's
meant for hunting sea kings while
frankie was working with tom they were
visited by the roger pirates on their
final voyage and odin even invited
frankie to join their crew however
because of what had happened with his
parents frankie wasn't the biggest fan
of pirates and disliked the idea of
becoming one himself when frankie was 12
tom was put on trial for helping the
former king of the pirates gold roger by
creating the ship the oro jackson this
would have likely resulted in his death
but tom made a deal for his freedom
offering to build a sea train over the
next 10 years which would allow easy
travel between water 7 and emmy's lobby
and tom would of course not only go on
to create those tracks but also three
other lines for the c train to travel
with as well which had an effect of
social good more than enough to make up
for building the oro jackson the marines
were just about to let him off free
but spawndom was charged with finding
the blueprints of pluton used the battle
frankies to attack the area in an
attempt to frame tom or more
specifically frankie tom would take
responsibility for this as he didn't
want frankie to get in trouble and was
sentenced to death as a result
frankie becomes filled with guilt and
regret for having built weapons that
hurt people and more importantly that
had put tom's life in danger
spondom accuses frankie of making these
weapons and frankie begins to denounce
making them but tom quickly punches him
in the face saying
not my ships that's the one thing you
just can't say no matter what the ship
is when you start building it it's
neither good or evil i don't care what
kind of ship you make but even if the
ship you've made could hurt somebody
even if it could bring ruined the entire
world its only parent must give it love
you mustn't deny that which you've
created the ship isn't to blame when a
man makes a ship he makes it a part of
himself
and this kind of admits to the world
government that tom is not only not
sorry for building the oro jackson but
he also sees it as an extension of
himself
secondly it teaches frankie to take
responsibility for the things that he
makes in the future
knowing what frankie wanted to do for
having his ships be defiled by spawndom
and knowing that his own fate was
already sealed tom hit spondom so hard
that saint charlo started thinking that
he must have got off lucky tom then
turns to the judge and says that he will
admit to being behind the attack but he
asks a favor in return saying that he
would like to make the crime that was
being excused by the creation of the sea
train applicable to the crimes committed
today
rather than for building the oro jackson
this would still effectively result in
tom getting the death penalty but it
would absolve iceberg and frankie for
any wrongdoings tom then turns to
frankie and tells him not to torture
himself because tom had a wonderful life
and his wish was fulfilled water 7 which
was falling apart only 10 years ago was
now full of life he had helped hundreds
or thousands of people and with that tom
collapses and spondom the big guy he is
takes the opportunity to try and arrest
frankie and iceberg only for the judge
to call him back and saying to release
them and can we just have a quick moment
to appreciate the judge here we often
see the world government painted as
these evil heartless kind of monsters
but this man was genuinely invested in
bringing good to as many people as
possible
he knew he had to make some kind of
action but he always chose the way that
would help the most people he chose the
path that let water 7 prosper he chose
the path that let frankie and iceberg go
free he is a surprisingly good dude and
it's always interesting to see
especially because he's so closely tied
to emmy's lobby which is supposed to be
almost the center of the world
government's corruption outside of like
marijuana back to the exact opposite of
that though spahnam goes over and kicks
tom's face which lands him a swift bat
to the face from frankie and while that
was absolutely deserved the c train
begins taking off all the same with tom
aboard frankie tries to get in front of
it to stop it but literally nothing he
does even slows it down and as the c
train plows straight through him he
begins to think that he would love to
make a dreamship one day that could
proudly sail to the end of the world the
people of water 7 iceberg included
believe that frankie was dead but in
reality he was barely holding on to life
in the middle of the ocean
he found his way to an abandoned ship
that was passing by and decided that the
first thing he would need to do is fix
his useless body and it wouldn't be
until four years had passed when iceberg
was working towards becoming the mayor
of water 7 that a man named cuddy flam
would try to get an appointment with him
only to be sent away he later meets with
this man in secret obviously he's a
little bit surprised to see frankie and
frankie explains that he had to fix his
body with scraps of metal that he had
found and make himself a cyborg in the
process just to stay alive iceberg
realizes that the government had hounded
tom for the blueprints of pluton and
that they would eventually likely come
for him next so he tells cuddy flam to
instead only call himself frankie from
now on and to take the blueprints and
get off the island this would be the
safest way to keep them hidden iceberg
starts to walk away after giving the
blueprints over to frankie and as he
does he starts to talk about how he can
likely never forgive frankie for what he
did but at the same time he wants him to
know that he still trusts him enough to
give him the blueprints and that he is
very happy that his friend is alive now
of course frankie did decide to go by
frankie going forward but he refused to
leave the island so that if anything
ever happened he would be able to
protect iceberg from the world
government on top of that he would go
into the water 7 backstreets where he
was attacked by zombia and his gang
however he very quickly laid out the
entire group and told them that the
backstreets now belong to him later he
finds mozu and kiwi drunk out of their
goddamn mines in the middle of the day
and swaps out their booze for cola
before recruiting them
and this was the beginning of the
frankie family water 7's mafia-like
group of ship dismantlers who robbed
incoming pirates on the surface frankie
had become the crime boss of water 7 but
in reality he was just trying to atone
for his sins
he was taking in the lost and the broken
people of the town and giving them a
place where they belonged he was giving
them a family not only that but he was
fending off looters and pirates who
would cause the town harm and by running
the crime in the city he could also keep
it under his own control so that nothing
too serious ever happened and while the
frankie family was definitely rowdy for
lack of a better term they were in
reality the protectors of water 7. that
said he was still robbing people and
while most of the money would be blown
on parties and cola he was also saving
up to buy wood from the treasure tree
atom so that he could one day build his
dreamship the same ship that he would
one day build for the straw hats only a
few years later
now on to the oldest member of the crew
being brooke the earliest thing we know
about brooke is that at some point
before joining the brumbar pirates he
was the leader of a battle convoy for a
kingdom that we know nothing about kind
of makes me wonder if we're ever going
to get more information on that island
or what's going on there now but either
way this is where brooke learned his
unique style of swordsmanship
eventually brooke would join captain
yorkie and the rumbar pirates a musical
pirate ship that aimed to bring smiles
to children wherever they traveled along
the way they had met with a young island
whale that they named laboon he had been
separated from his pod and brook had the
idea that they should play music for him
to cheer him up this worked and laboon
kinda became the chopper of the group
with brooke becoming the one that he was
closest to but then a problem came up
the rumbar pirates were headed to the
grand line and it would be too dangerous
for laboon to join them on top of that
once the balloon crossed into the grand
line there would be no way for him to
return to his pod ever again so the
group tried to convince the young whale
to stay behind but the boom refused the
pirates then tried to ignore the whale
to try and convince him to leave and at
first it seemed to work and he vanished
but once they entered the grand line
laboon revealed himself again the rumbar
ship needed repairs so they spent the
next three months fixing it at kroxx's
lighthouse all the while partying with
their blubbery chum the group then
decided to leave the boone in croaks's
care promising that they would return
after finishing making their way around
the world by then lagoon would be grown
enough and he could accompany them on
their next journey however things didn't
exactly work out like that the grand
line was treacherous and quickly became
a difficult journey for them things went
from bad to worse though when yorkie
fell fatally ill with an incurable
disease the captain made the decision to
separate himself and other infected crew
members from the rest of the crew in
order to keep them safe he and the other
sickos would try to escape the grand
line by going through the comm belt
which is something that definitely
didn't work but before they went out on
this journey lying on what would
effectively be his deathbed yorkie asked
two things of brooke firstly he asked
him to say hi to laboon for him when he
managed to make it around the world
and secondly he asked brooke to play
bing sake for him one last time with
just over half the crew left the
remaining rumbar pirates continued into
the grand line on a new ship with brook
as the captain even gaining a bounty as
they continued his fortune was not all
in the rear view though as the crew
sailed into the florian triangle they
had barely survived an encounter with
another crew but even having escaped the
battle they were still in danger as the
other crew had tipped their weapons in
poison and killed the rumbar pirates
doctor and to make matters worse they
had also broken their rudder so
effectively they were cursed to drift
aimlessly lost and slowly dying in the
florian triangle the crew had one thing
bringing them hope
brooke had eaten the yomi yomi nomi and
because of that would get a second
chance at life he pulled out a tone dial
and asked the crew to record the boone's
favorite song for him so that when brook
eventually made it back to life he could
bring it to laboom and play it for him
even if the rumbar crew could not make
it back to laboon at least their voices
would so they start playing bing sake as
the rumbar pirates slowly fade one after
another this continued until all that
was left was a quartet
and then a trio
a duet and finally
just the accompaniment in a solo act
brooke would die soon after and
eventually his soul would return to the
world to seek out his body because of
his devil fruit however the body was
lost in the florian triangle and by the
time his soul found his body it was just
bones and an afro upon finding his new
skeleton body brook gathered the corpses
of all of his friends and brought them
to the coffins deep within the ship to
let them rest for the next 50 years
brooke would be trapped in the florian
triangle alone on a ship with nothing
but his dreams and memories of his
friends to keep him company five years
prior to the straw hats arriving brook's
ship drifted onto thriller bark he
explored the island looking for
materials to fix his rudder but instead
found gekko maurya's zombies he was
captured and had his shadows stolen from
him before they left him back on his
ship adrift in the florian triangle now
not even being able to go into sunlight
without turning to ash so you know he
was having a bit of a rough time he did
eventually manage to make it back to
thriller bark though and learned the
secrets of using salt to defeat the
zombies from dr hogbach eventually he
would come face to face with his own
shadow who is now inhabiting the body of
the sword's master ryuma
and despite his best efforts he would be
defeated and forced to run away over the
next five years brook would continue to
train on his own in hopes of defeating
his shadow and when the straw hats
finally arrived it was his chance to do
just that or at least to watch zoro do
so and finally our newest straw hat
jinbe jinbe was raised in an orphanage
which would eventually become the
fishman district along with arlong and
fisher tiger he trained in fishman
karate and proved himself a prodigy by
earning a black belt by the time he was
still a child as he grew up he would
eventually become a soldier in the
neptunian army jinbe back then was very
weary and doubtful of fishman and
humanity coming together and saw
otohime's preaching as something that
was always going to be fruitless
believing that history had been very
clear about the way that humanity saw
fish men and believing it would never
change at the same time though while he
wasn't interested in otohime's quest he
was still a devout subject to the queen
and wouldn't allow arlong to steal or
damage the signatures that she had
collected and that of shows jinbe's
personality in a nutshell
even if he disagrees with something or
sees no value in it he would never allow
injustice or pointless hatred of any
kind it's a moral code that defines who
he is he and arlon have a quick almost
sanji and zorro-like back and forth
where they're just kind of playfully
disrespecting each other but they're
interrupted when one of my personal
favorite characters in the series fisher
tiger returns after a long adventure
tiger was at one point the de facto
leader of the fishman district but now
he was more of a local hero than
anything and that hero had just returned
after doing something that shook the
world he opposed the celestial dragons
and freed their slaves if he were to
remain in fishman island then the entire
region would become the target of
humanity's wrath well more so than it
already was jinbei leaves his post in
the neptunian army and along with arlong
and his crew they joined in under
fischer's son pirates to avoid
discrimination between the former slaves
and the former free fishmen every member
of the crew was branded with a sun that
was used to cover the mark of celestial
dragons on those who used to be slaves
tiger approached neptune and otohine to
tell them about his journey and explain
what he had done and how the lives of
the slaves were hell and when asked what
he had seen tiger responded that he had
simply saw humans and what he meant by
that was that he had seen all the evil
that they had to offer and so we see
this kind of schism in the parallel
paths between humanity and fish men
otohime would work towards cohabitation
and peace while fisher would work
towards freedom and independence as they
voyaged the sun pirates would regularly
be attacked by marines looking to gather
escaped slaves but now with the mark of
the sun there was no proof of their
former bondage the some pirates caused
so much of a stir that they actually
garnered the attention of vice admiral
borsellino that said despite everything
that was happening fisher had a strict
rule against killing humans who attacked
them much to arlong and even jinbe's
confusion but tiger explained that the
second that they start killing people
they lose the war and lower themselves
to the level of the evil humans they
were not fighting for revenge they were
acting for freedom and liberty tiger
understood that for every human that
they kill
more hatred would arise towards the
fishman race they would only be
increasing the plight of the people and
innocents from their next generation who
would suffer as a result jinbe would
later meet with tiger in the middle of
the night and tiger would open up to him
explaining that he believed otohime's
path to be a better one and that he
believed she probably saw him no
different than the bloodthirsty arlong
but more importantly he tells jinbe that
the one thing that he genuinely fears is
the demon within himself the next three
years would pass with both otohime and
fisher's efforts continuing but things
shifted when the sun pirates came across
a young girl her name was koala and she
had been freed from marijuana in
fisher's raid but she had been stuck far
from home since that had happened three
years ago and now the sun pirates were
going to agree to take her home which
believe it or not upset arlong quite a
bit go figure koala at this point was a
broken person
completely shattered from her time as a
slave she was unable to stop smiling or
even to complain for fear of being
tortured even when arlong punches her
and leaves a trail of her blood across
the deck she just tears off a piece of
fabric from her pants and starts to
scrub the floor apologizing for making
it dirty and promising to work hard
without sleep begging them not to hit
her anymore jean bae approaches her and
asks what she's doing while bleeding and
again she just begs and promises that
she won't cry so she hopes they won't
kill her he asked if she's so afraid of
them and she just says yes but she wants
to see her mother so she needs to be
brave
explaining that if she works hard they
might not kill her so she'll do her best
to be useful guys when i say this scene
breaks my heart every time i watch it
this is a criminally underrated moment
in the story and it's a shame that no
one talks about it fisher sees koala
falling apart and orders her into his
cabin where he brands the mark of the
sun pirates over the celestial dragon
mark explaining that the mark of the
dragons would only bring painful
memories for the rest of her life koala
passes out from the pain but quickly
wakes up and tells them that yes she
lost consciousness but she didn't cry so
they don't have to kill her but before
she can finish speaking tiger explodes
saying and why shouldn't you cry we
aren't the same as those slave driving
monsters he tells her to watch as he
picks up his pistol and tosses it into
the ocean saying that his crew kills no
one and then turning away and saying
let's get moving we need to get this
girl back home as koala finally breaks
down crying when they finally start
heading towards koala's home island
arlong does stir the pot a little bit
asking koala if her parents taught her
to look down on fish men then going on
on his typical
racial superiority and humans are evil
speech however jinbe cuts in to correct
him saying that yes
some humans are hateful but others who
look at them like koala does aren't
filled with hate they're just filled
with fear he begins to question what
they might be so afraid of and koala
explains that they're only afraid
because they don't know anything about
fishman this putting jinbe in a spot to
wonder if otohime's message really is
the right path and learning more about
one another could actually lead to peace
weeks later and it's time to drop koala
off and even macro who was so
cold-hearted that he sold other fish men
into slavery is crying because he's
going to miss her so much fisher says
that he'll take koala to her village
personally and koala promises to tell
everyone about how nice fish men are
again jinbe and arlong kind of quickly
cross their moral swords as arlong says
she'll grow up to be just like the rest
of humanity and saying that jinbe has
changed if he thinks otherwise and
things are great as koala reaches home
but this is a one piece backstory so
things need to go to hell as tiger walks
back to his ship he's ambushed by rear
admiral strawberry and a small army of
marines they were apparently tipped off
by the people of koala's village meaning
the tiger had gone out of his way to
help this girl and even rescued her from
slavery
only for her people to betray him at the
same time the sun pirates ship was also
being attacked and sunk but luckily all
the fishman managed to escape they steal
a marine ship
but tiger was already mortally wounded
tiger apparently had a rare blood type
but by taking a human blood transfusion
he could be saved
however he forbids it screaming saying
that he doesn't want to live with their
blood in his veins the blood of those
who hated fish men and the blood of
those who captured him and made him a
slave for years we learned that tiger
managed to escape but couldn't leave the
other slaves behind so he went back to
free them too he tells his men that he
lived selfishly and caused otohime's
dream a lot of trouble but that she is
correct and that everyone should strive
for the same goal that she has
however even with this mentality he
believed that his generation was kind of
a lost cause and it would be koala's
generation who would make the changes
that they need to do to eventually see
peace and as a result he begs his men to
never speak of the betrayal and tragedy
that happened on this day
so that the next generation could grow
up without any stained views tiger says
that while there are plenty of kind
humans the demon in his heart refuses to
accept humanity and he will never be
able to love them jinbe begs him to
reconsider and tells him that he's a
hero to fishman island to which tiger
just smiles and says that he was happy
that he was able to help those worse off
than he was and with that he closes his
eyes and passes on arlong would go on to
rampage trying to attack koala's
hometown for betraying tiger but
borsolino stopped him and imprisoned him
and impel down when interrogated arlong
still respected tiger's dying wish
though as he told a lie about what had
happened saying that tiger died because
humanity refused to give him blood for a
transfusion rather than him rejecting
one jinbe on the other hand continued to
lead the sun pirates with the philosophy
that they would never take a life he
would also send a letter back to ryugu
palace explaining what had really
happened and reigniting the passion of
otohime though the citizens would all
rescind their signatures after hearing
what had happened to fisher tiger as
time passed jinbe continued to gain
notoriety and his bounty raised to a
quarter of a billion berries as such the
world government offered him a position
as a warlord of the sea and he would
accept with the hopes that taking this
position could better the relationship
between humanity and fishman in doing so
he also released arlong from impel down
though and rather than choosing to kill
his old friend he allowed him to roam
free which eventually allowed him to
find his way to kokoyashi village jinbe
would continue to act in a way that
would lead towards peace between humans
and fish men so even when hodi jones
framed a human for killing otohime jinbe
wanted to hide that human's body rather
than cause a panic of course jinbe would
years later be called to fight with the
marines in the battle of marineford but
refused to stand against whitebeard who
had always acted as a figure of peace on
fishman island this resulted in jinbe
ending up in a cell in impel down with
ace where we are first introduced to him
and where he ultimately finds luffy as
they escape and there we go another
behemoth of a video covering these straw
hats backstories let me know which one
is your favorite in the comments down
below if i had to rank them from worst
to best i would probably go usopp zorro
sanji's vinsmoke stuff luffy frankie
chopper robin
sanji and zeph nami brook and jinbe is a
personal favorite of mine i'm sure you
all disagree so let me know why in the
comments if you want to check out the
last video i did on anime uproar all
about the abilities of the straw hat
crew be sure to check that out in the
description down below and of course if
you enjoy this video and you want to see
more like it in the future be sure to
leave a like and support the channel and
of course remember to subscribe so you
can stay up to date when more awesome
one piece content is released you can
also follow anime upload on twitter at
anime uproar or myself over on my own
channel axel beats thank you guys so
much for watching i hope you all enjoyed
and until next time remember to stay
excellent